I definitely find specifically with
boyfriend because it was such a huge
part of me finding my own identity and
embracing my queerness and it like makes
me emotional every time I talk about it
but it was it was such a like a like a
key to a gate for me into stepping into
myself holy in a way that I never knew
if I was going to be privileged enough
to find those pieces of myself
um and and exist as that person right
because that's like the fear the fear is
that you exist as yourself holy and the
world cracks open and everything ends
and all the lights go out
um and when the song came out and when I
saw the people were emotionally
connecting to it I think I was really
panicked for some reason just because I
wasn't expecting it yeah and then over
time it was like it melded into this
gorgeous like something meaningful for
me being something meaningful for others
I'm sure you've had that before it
becomes this like especially when it's
something about you know identity and
queerness and how people view themselves
being so personal and intimate and
finding empowerment in it when it's
something that you know can sometimes
feel very heavy to carry alone identity
and I've found it incredibly special and
meaningful and such a surprise such a
beautiful surprise we have a surprise
for you you have a surprise yes we do
was that me um in honor of over 1
million records sold man we're excited
to present you with the RR double a plan
[Applause]
I was so excited when we finally were
getting I was like I want to give it to
her we've got his latest single is
called bad idea and it's available
wherever you get your music check it out
y'all
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]